welcome to exploring computing
today's video is computer security
defensive techniques
so in the last video we saw lots of ways
your computer can get attacked
what sort of things can we do to protect
ourselves
so that's what this video is all about
so the first thing i want to talk about
is firewalls
we'll talk about corporate firewalls
first and then we'll talk about personal
firewalls
so first of all let's consider what
happens if we have a company with no
firewall
um so we've got a company internal
intranet
and every computer in the internet can
access the internet
this means that all our computers
are vulnerable to attacks from outside
it also means potentially
you know we've got somebody who wants to
do something
internally uh like maybe we've got
somebody who's spying they can
send information out of the company
there's no controls at all so this is
this is clearly a bad situation
so what a firewall computer is is it's a
computer that stands between the
corporate intranet
and the wider internet so it's going to
prevent malicious
traffic from going into the company it
can also prevent malicious information
from going out of the company
there's a variety of different things
that the firewall can do
so one thing it could do is it can block
specific applications
or it could alternatively white list
certain applications
so basically it's going to be looking at
all the traffic coming in and let's say
somebody's trying to access
like ftp on one of our computers it'll
be like hey that computer's not supposed
to be doing file transfer i don't know
why you're
while you're trying to access that
computer and try and file transfer from
it
or it could be um we'll we'll talk about
in a minute about
uh which computers are actually allowed
to access the internet but
uh you know it could say oh that's not
the right computer to be accessing files
from so this looks kind of suspicious
um it can either block certain ip
numbers or white list certain ip numbers
so
uh you know we can limit which computers
either employees can access or we can
limit which of our computers outsiders
can access
it can also scan for for information in
uh incoming or outgoing
traffic so i actually work for a
company i was actually a visiting
researcher at ibm federal systems
and we were not allowed to use our
computers including our email for
private purposes
and i was told that they actually would
scan the emails to look for words like
football and email because
that was a sign that you were using your
emails for personal purposes
this was just on the cusp when normal
non-computer scientists were starting to
use email and i actually told them that
i did not think this policy was going to
fly with the
next generation of graduates but uh
they said that the government contracts
they were on
did not allow the use of on-site
computers for personal email
anyway all right uh
so as i alluded to a minute ago um
if you want to get a little bit fancier
what you can do is you have
all the internal computers um
sending all their traffic through the
firewall computer which is protecting
both from outside influences and people
on the inside doing things they
shouldn't
and sending that information outside of
the intranet
but you've also got a series of
additional computers such as
web servers or file servers which are
given direct
access to the internet so like let's say
we've got a product that we have and
we've got some
you know maybe some updates or patches
uh that we have a file server that
people can go
go ahead and download those from you
know those would be clearly something
that
um people from outside of our company
should be able to access similarly the
web server that's obviously something
people should be able to access
and so a more sophisticated art
architecture says that we've got these a
special
set of computers or a smaller sub
network that's referred to as the dmz um
this is short for demilitarized zone
uh which is a general term but it's
probably most
widely known for the dmz between north
and south korea so the idea is
you know we've got uh i suppose we're
south korea in this in this scenario
um and we've got that demilitarized zone
that's uh
carefully protected um and then there's
the wild west outside which is the
internet
okay modern computers also
have a personal firewall so um
even though you know some of you will be
working for companies
uh that have firewalls but you all have
computers
um many of you have well i suppose all
of you have computers that you use for
personal purposes
not for work purposes so uh there is
what's referred to as a personal
firewall this is uh
generally part of the operating system
at this point
and so the personal firewall is going to
act similar to what we just saw a minute
ago with the corporate firewall so first
of all let's take a look at the
situation with no firewall
with no firewall all of your programs
just communicate directly with the
internet
and the internet communicates directly
with your programs
what the personal firewall does is
uh again typically part of the operating
system
this is going to act as an intermediary
where all
traffic from programs on your computer
need to go through the personal firewall
and the personal firewall will either
say
yeah okay you're authorized to send this
information out or
i don't know what you're doing you're
not allowed to send information out and
so the idea here is
let's say something gets installed on
your computer that shunt like let's say
you ran a treasure horse or something um
and now you've got this program it's a
key logger
uh hopefully the personal firewall will
prevent that key logger from sending
information out to the hacker
um you know it will try and send
information on the internet and
hopefully the personal firewall will be
like
um you're not you're not allowed to send
information
off of the computer so i don't know what
you're doing but i'm
not going to let you do it similarly
people are constantly trying to get onto
the computer
particularly if you've got a server
that's running 24 hours a day
i've talked to different students at
rccs in the dorms who are in charge of
the computers and dormitories
who've run servers before and they say
that it's surprising how many
times their computers get hit by people
trying to get on
so what the personal firewall does in
the opposite direction is
it only allows packets through that are
uh for services that you are currently
using so you know like my computers
don't use
ftp they're not acting as ftp servers so
if somebody were
to try and access my computer using the
secure ftp protocol
my firewall should say um
we're not a secure uh ftp
server i don't know why you think you're
accessing it but clearly
your traffic is unwanted you are most
likely to run it to the personal
firewall you used to have to turn these
on explicitly but
at this point i think all the operating
systems are are running them
by default you're most likely to run
into
the firewall when you install a new
program
so typically what would happen is if
you're installing a program that
needs to use the internet like let's say
i hear this this cool new game and
uh you know my friends want me to play
with them so i go ahead and install on
my computer
well in order for me to play this game
with my friends
um it needs to send information off of
my computer so
uh the firewall software would say okay
patrick
you're trying to run this game and uh
it's asking if it can
send information out to the internet
should i go ahead and approve
access to the internet for this
particular program and then you can say
yes
i have noticed that a surprising number
of programs these days seem to want
access to the internet
my suspicion is many of them want access
to the internet
for update purposes which is
a good thing generally but it's not
always clear
so um yeah i don't have any great
suggestions
but certainly if you have things
asking for access to the internet and
it's not something that you think you
installed
at minimum you should go ahead and
google it sometimes it will be
part of a pre-existing program so for
example
um i run adobe products that's how i'm
making this video right now
um and this diagram you're looking at
this was created in photoshop this video
you're listening to right now is being
done with adobe premiere
adobe installs a whole bunch of junk on
your computer i'm sure it all does
something
but like i run into when for example i
try and shut down the computer
and it won't shut down because these
adobe things will not stop
running and i'm like i don't know what
those things are
they're not the names of the
applications and it turns out they're
like
helper programs that adobe has installed
so
it's certainly possible for something to
get installed on your computer
and ask for access to the internet and
actually be legitimate
but definitely google it if you're not
sure what it is you don't remember
installing something super recently
or even if you do and that's not what's
asking to access the internet you should
double check it
um anyway so that's the personal
firewall
okay our next topic is proxy servers
so uh proxy server is used to
basically allow somebody who is trying
to access a resource and they aren't
able to access that resource directly
access it anyway so
i'm going to use an example where we're
trying to access something that
we can normally access from stanford
but there's a couple other situations
where this could be used and i'll talk
about those in a minute
okay so uh let's say there's a
restricted resource that stanford pays
for so for example
if you're looking for books on computer
science you're trying to learn a new
programming language you want to learn
more about html and css
as a stanford affiliate you have access
to safari online which provides a
vast number of books on a wide range of
computer related topics it's actually a
really great resource
so uh if i try and access safari online
and i'm on campus what happens is safari
online
can look at who's trying to access it
and i could say oh that's a stanford
computer stanford
is allowed to access
our resources so i'm going to go ahead
and let that request go through
so that works that's great and then
somebody else on campus tries to access
it
same thing and so what it's really doing
is it's looking at the ip numbers and as
we all know
now uh ip numbers for stanford computers
all have the same
initial prefix numbers and so it's
pretty easy for
a computer like safari online servers to
tell
oh this is a standard computer now
suppose i am no longer
on campus i'm at home what is going to
happen
um now if you live on campus you're
still golden but if you're not living on
campus that's kind of a problem
and so what stanford does to support
those of us who are not living on campus
is they run what's called a proxy server
and the way the proxy server is going to
work is okay so let's say
i'm not using the proxy server i am
trying to access this resource
from my computer which is on comcast
what happens is i access that resource
directly
from my computer at home and the
resource
says safari online says i don't know
who you are i don't recognize your ip
number
what's your credit card number so that
doesn't work
unless you buy a personal account
obviously if you
create a personal uh safari online
account and pay for it with your
own credit card that they'd be happy to
do that but you can't use the
stanford access because you're not a
stanford computer so what we're going to
do here is
instead of accessing our restricted
resource directly
instead we're going to access it through
the proxy server so we will send our
request to the proxy server
the proxy server will send the request
onto the restricted resource
the restricted resource will look at the
iep number where that
request is coming from it'll say oh it's
coming from our proxy
it doesn't necessarily know it's
processor but it says
oh it's coming from a stanford ip number
because the proxy server is a stanford
ip number the stanford server
is on stanford campus and it says okay
that's fine
and so it will send the results back to
the proxy server and the proxy server
will go ahead and send the data back
on to me so um
stanford does run a proxy server and
this is how you can access
a variety of different resources uh what
are some other uses of proxy servers
well um i mentioned earlier about
working for a company that did not want
us to use computers for
personal purposes another thing that
that firewall can do is it can block
access to things like sports illustrated
or like let's say there's the stanford
cal games going on and you're stuck at
work and you're working over the weekend
you're like i feel like i should be able
to access this
anyway well what you can do and be super
careful about this because
um i t can get really pissed off and
your company can get really pissed off
so
don't do this and unless you're sure
your boss is okay with it
uh you know if it's if you're working
over the weekend they might be okay with
it
um anyway so what you can do is you can
work with a proxy server and send your
request to watch the game
through the proxy server and have the
proxy server forward your request onto
espn and then get
get around the restriction not being
able to access espn directly that way
um this also used to be used to get
around the great firewall of china
and so the idea would be china blocks
access to
basically anything that makes the
government look bad
so they don't want you to be able to
read the new york times
and i want you to be able to read the
washington post for example so
if you were in china you used to be able
to get around that by sending the
request to get to new york times not
directly because you sent it directly
the the computers controlling access
in and out of china will look at and say
you're not allowed to access new york
times
so what it would do you would do instead
is you would access a proxy server and
say
proxy server can you send a request out
of new york times
and then the proxy server would access
new york times new york times would send
the articles
to the proxy server and the proxy server
would send it back through and as long
as
the great firewall of china was not
aware of
that particular proxy server would not
notice the ip numbers
being a problem whereas if it saw the ip
address for new york times i'd be like
that
that's not allowed but unfortunately the
great firewall of china has gotten more
and more sophisticated
and so this is generally not going to
work anymore um another issue with the
proxy
server is that the traffic is not
encrypted so
whether you're trying to get around the
great firewall of china or you're trying
to get access to espn because you're
working over the weekend and you want to
listen to the game
big game in both cases
that request is going to go in what's
referred to as clear text so
uh if the firewall is smart enough it
can go ahead and look and say hey
i see that you're sending this to this
ip number i don't know about that's not
espn.com but if i
scan the text of your request i can see
that there's a reference to espn.com in
here what's going on
anyway so that is a potential excuse
with proxy servers but
you know for things like accessing the
resources that stanford is paid for when
you are off campus proxy servers work
great
okay um a more sophisticated situation
happens with virtual private networks uh
and vpns can be used for
some of the same things as proxy servers
but they can also be used from some
other purposes as well so
um let's say uh we have a company
it has the company intranet and
um that's basically all the traffic in
the
corporate intranet and remember an
intranet is an internal network that
uses internet protocols
all the traffic in the corporate
internet is uh
we're not worrying about that traffic
we're assuming that there is no
nobody inside the corporation that is
doing something they shun that's trying
to steal our data our information
but we are concerned with all the
information outside and that's why we
have that firewall computer out there
now suppose um we set up a different
office in a different location
um usually i use hong kong as my
location but given the current uh
situation in hong kong right now they
may not be the best example but
um yeah all right let's say let's use
tokyo let's say we set up an office in
tokyo
and so now the question is we've got a
palo alto office and we got our
corporate internet in palo alto
and then we have a corporate internet
over in tokyo
how are we going to connect the two
together and what happens when data is
sent from one office to the next office
well the safest thing we can do if we're
really concerned with security is
we lease our own private lines and
the only way somebody can actually
eavesdrops in our conversation is to
physically tap into the lines now
clearly that that is technically
possible but uh to physically
tap into the lines depending on how
sophisticated our attackers are but
yeah that's that's going to take a fair
amount of work
otherwise if we don't do that what's
going to happen here is
when we send information from
say the palo alto office the tokyo
office
we're going to just use the internet to
send the information because
that's by far the cheapest thing to do
renting our own lines or
worse yet laying our own lines it's
going to be super super expensive
so we're just going to use the internet
but here's the thing let's say we've got
two computers sending information
through the internet
one's in our palo alto office and one's
in our tokyo office and
so what do people
outside of our company c when that
traffic gets sent well
they see everything because it's all
being sent with ip packets and if
somebody is
between our computer and the computer
we're sending it to
they have to be on that chain or that
sequence of
computers that our iep packets get sent
through they're going to see everything
they're going to see who the sender is
they're going to see who the recipient
is and unless the contents are
explicitly encrypted they're going to be
able to see the contents as well
now one thing you could do is you could
just encrypt all the information
but um it's possible just simply knowing
whose computer is sending information to
whose computer
they may be able to get a lot of
information so for example they know
that the co
is sending a lot of uh packets to
the computer uh owned by
an acquisitions director they might be
like oh that company's about to make an
acquisition let's see how we can take
advantage of this
so what you really want to do is one you
want to make sure that people can't
identify which specific computers are
sending data to which other specific
computers
and then two in addition you want the
data to always be encrypted
instead of having to have the people
explicitly encrypt their data and so a
virtual private network's going to
actually handle both of these
and the way this is going to work is
with the virtual private network
when i sent information from a computer
in
one part of the network to a computer in
the other part of the network
my information is going to pass through
a computer in the dmz and that computer
is going to
encrypt all the information it's not
only going to encrypt
the actual data i'm sending it's also
going to encrypt the
the ip number of the sender and the ip
number of the recipient
it's going to replace the ip number of
the sender with itself
and it will replace the ip number of the
recipient with its equivalent dmz
computer on the other side
um and so then what we're it's going to
do is it's going to go ahead and send
that
th that packet to the other dmz computer
in the tokyo office
the dmz computer in the tokyo office
is going to decrypt all the information
thus revealing the original sender and
the original recipient
and uh decrypting the information in the
packet
and then it will get passed on to the uh
the actual destination computer
so as far as what people on the internet
are able to see they'll see that the two
dmz computers are communicating so
they'll see that the tokyo office
and the palo alto office are
communicating but they won't know which
specific computers are communicating
they won't be able to identify like what
type of communication is
taking place it's another thing that uh
potentially people could see with the
other
the other without the vpn it's like what
sort of communication is this
and they won't be able to see the
contents at all so uh big win
um so in addition to allowing us to
connect two different offices as if we
had one big
network without having to worry about
what happens when the information
travels through the internet not having
to worry about the security there
and this can also be done with the
individual computers so
you know if i'm operating from home or
uh
i'm out on the road i'm operating from
my hotel
the way this would work is my computer
would
bundle everything up and encrypt it and
then send it to the computer in
the office in dmz and then would be
decrypted there
you may also hear about private vpns
this is a currently a relatively hot
topic um and so why would somebody want
a
personal vpn or well
i think probably the main reason why
people are getting these is
it hides your internet activity from the
internet service provider or
any other nefarious parties that are out
there um and so
the idea here is that uh one of the
reasons why you might want to do this is
it turns out that
the trump administration has changed the
rules so that
our isps like comcast can now sell
our web browsing information to whoever
wants to pay for it now most of the
major isps have promised they won't do
that
although well actually i suppose i was
going to say although
given the current circumstances they may
not be doing well financially they may
change their mind
and that is always a possibility
although i would see
i would assume that under the current
circumstances internet service providers
are
probably doing pretty well i mean you
got to pick a business to be in
uh being in a business that supports
people working from home is probably a
good business to be in
anyway so uh bottom line is
they are now allowed to sell information
on all your internet habits
um most of the main internet service
providers have promised they won't do
that but they are now legally allowed to
do that so maybe you don't want that to
happen
and so uh if you contract with a vpn
what will happen is
um as far as comcast sees or you know
att or whoever your provider is
they'll just see you're communicating
with a vpn
what the ultimate server that you want
to talk to is
that's hidden from them they just see
encrypted packets going from you to your
vpn
personal vpns can also be used to
simulate being in a different country so
if the vpn has connections in different
countries you can say
oh i want to connect to the vpn and
pretend i'm in
tokyo or i want to pretend i'm in
australia
um and so what will happen is
your information will get bundled up but
we get sent to
the vpn and and the vpn will have a
server in australia
or a server in tokyo or wherever why do
you want to do this well
one thing it can be used for is in some
cases
you can access information that's
regionally logged
so uh this doesn't work with everybody
um
so you should poke around and do your
research
uh to make sure that the resources that
you're looking for
will allow access by vpns and my
impression is some vpns do a bit
better than other vpns but now like
maybe
there's a tv show you really want to
watch and it's available in europe
but it's not available in the us and if
you try and access directly from the u.s
they say hey
that's a us ip number we aren't licensed
to uh
to show this uh to people in the united
states
um so if your vpn will allow you to
pretend that
say you're in italy and then you just
connect to the vpn
as far as the service provider sees
you're coming from italy it's like
okay that's fine i can go ahead and show
you this show
issues with vpns is kind of related or
the vpns can get blocked by various
websites or by various streaming
services so it's possible for the
streaming service to be like this is a
vpn
um this seems kind of sketchy
i wonder if you're trying to get around
our regional locks i am not going to
show you any video also some financial
websites will block you
and this is basically because they know
vpns hide
where the information is coming from and
they're like you might be a hacker
this looks kind of sketch i'm only going
to let you in
if you are coming from a service
provider that i recognize is normally
legitimate like say
a t verizon comcast something like that
another issue with vpns is there's a
greater chance that you are going to run
into those annoying
captchas where you have to type in words
or you have to click on
you know click on the crosswalk things
um and that is again because the
websites
are are like you're coming from a vpn
this is potentially much sketchier than
if you're coming from a regular service
provider
i want to make sure that you are a
actual human being not a computer trying
to hack the website or a computer trying
to
perform a distributed denial of service
attack so
you know prove to me that you're human
being so um
while vpns do have some advantages
personal vpns do have some advantages
they can also cause some problems
okay what else can you do well if you
want the maximum security
for your computing system you should
just use an air gap
and air gap is the term we use when a
computer is completely disconnected from
the network
so there's a physical well this worked
better before there was wi-fi
there's a physical gap between your
computer and the internet
and uh this also means you shouldn't
have wi-fi or bluetooth or anything else
that allows you to remotely access it
so just provide an example let's say
stanford was super
concerned about protecting
the stanford grades what could they do
well they know that there are all sorts
of people at stanford
various stanford students who could be
probably pretty good hackers so
they're like we're going to prevent
access to the grade database
from anywhere on the internet it's just
going to be completely separated maybe
it's got its own little
internal intranet but that intranet is
completely separated from
the wider internet and there's no way to
cross that gap
without physically showing up and then
what we're going to do is
put guard dogs around let's say we'll
put an old union in the basement old
union we'll have guard dogs
will have you know mean looking people
around there
and you know so we're going to prevent
any access to this computer
and the only way you can access the
great computer is if you show up
you show your identification card to the
guards
um they hold the dogs back um
my dog right now is sleeping on the
floor completely not paying attention
which is probably good because you
probably heard her barking a fair amount
um and so that provides pretty good
security
because you know somebody needs to
physically be there
and again just emphasize you can't use
wi-fi right
uh if you if you allow wi-fi access and
somebody just drives their
van near the uh near the building and
they have a bunch of hackers there
with laptops and they access the wi-fi
network so no wi-fi at all
so what's the flip side of this the flip
side is it's a real pain
to get anything done with this so back
in the old days
when i submitted everybody's grades we
really had these bubble like scantron
sheets and we have to fill in all the
scantron details and then we would
hand them over to the departmental admin
and uh
he or she would take it to the main
administration building and they would
read it in so
you know air gaps give me maximum
protection
and also provide the maximum amount of
inconvenience
okay um we talked about problems with
email
and there are a number of secure email
systems that are out there it's just
that's not what most people use
um one thing to keep in mind when you
are looking at secure email systems
is that there are a variety of
potentially competing
objectives for secure email systems so
one thing we want is confidentiality i
think pretty much all of them want
confidentiality which means that
um you know people
out in the wider internet can't actually
see the email the email
is encrypted when it's shopping through
the internet but
uh some of the systems want
authentication so
we want to know for sure who sent this
particular email
on the other hand um and that seems like
a real obvious thing that of course
don't all the systems want this well not
necessarily because
one of the reasons why you might want a
secure email system is
you know if you're a human rights
activist or uh
you know your whistleblower or something
like that
you want to be able to send emails
securely to somebody
but you don't necessarily want it to be
easily identifiable who you are
so in some cases you really want
authentication
in other cases you want really want
anonymity and privacy
and in fact some of the secure email
systems really tell that they keep
no record of the ip addresses of the
people who are sending the information
um so again depending upon what you're
doing you might really want that ip
address to verify that this person
really is who they say they are or you
might want a system where
no you know if you're a whistleblower go
ahead and send me an email like maybe i
work for
the washington post i want a system
where people can go ahead and feel free
that they can send information to me
and it will be completely confidential
one issue that comes up is who has the
ability to decrypt the information
is the information decrypt on the server
does the server have access the keys
so these are all issues that can come up
particularly
in situations where you know maybe
you're in a country where you're
concerned with you're sending
information
about things that should not be going on
or human rights violations
and you're concerned that the government
will figure out who you are
and uh come down on you and so
these are different things that you you
can be concerned about you might be
concerned about like
if that information is on the server and
they get
a subpoena
are people going to be able to decrypt
the messages or is that
completely safe because they even the
company
storing the data does not have the keys
to decrypt it
okay um i mentioned this a couple times
before but
uh you know be aware that there's http
which is the standard version of http
and then there's https which is a secure
version
with with the standard regular http data
to and from
a web server is sent in what's referred
to as clear text
that means it is not encrypted with
https
traffic to and from the servers
encrypted
some web servers don't encrypt all
related data
and so most often i think the the
uh the images might not be encrypted um
sometimes the css
might not be encrypted and this may
trigger a warning from your web browser
so your web browser may say
hey you've got an https connection but
be aware that it's not
all being encrypted so typically that's
going to mean that there's some
some of the additional items associated
with the web page and may not be
encrypted it also could mean
like maybe there's a
a iframe we talked about iframes last
lecture you know i mean
so i mean there's a variety of different
situations so ideally you you you don't
want that to happen you want everything
to be encrypted
um and so along the same lines
some websites support both http and
https but they don't use https
because it's expensive basically
that encryption is expensive it requires
processing power and so
they say we're not gonna actually
i don't know what that means all right
that was fun
whatever i just said triggered siri
um so
encryption is uh expensive it
takes processing power to actually
encrypt things and so that increases
their cost because that means they need
more computing power
and so uh that's one of the reasons why
they won't necessarily encrypt
everything
one thing that you may want to get is
there's a plugin from the eff foundation
called https everywhere and
this plugin will force use of https when
it's available so
it'll basically be like no i really want
https
and as long as https is available on
server all the information will be sent
with https
another thing you might want to do is
disable javascript it turns out that um
so for a while i had a security phd
student who was
my ta for cs105 and this was one of his
biggest suggestions he said you know
if you want to be safe computing on the
internet
and the biggest thing that you can do is
you can disable javascript
so the issue here is client-side
javascript can be used in a variety of
different malicious ways
you know like we talked about the the
drive-by
download that's often triggered by
javascript
um sometimes there's uh
holes in the web browser security that
javascript can
concern manipulate so basically
disabling javascript will greatly
increase your security
on the other hand it will also make life
potentially pretty annoying
it makes things annoying because many
web pages require javascript for actual
use
and so i'll show you the tools in just a
second but a bunch of these tools will
allow you to white list certain
websites so you can say well when i'm on
the new york times
i trust new york times to not do
anything they shunt
so i'm gonna go ahead and put that on
the white list um
i would say definitely if you go to any
sketchy websites
uh ever you should turn off javascript
and even if you aren't going to sketchy
websites it turns out
occasionally the standard advertising
networks will
somehow allow somebody to put up stuff
out as advertisements on the standard
advertising networks that
uh use javascript to do some catchy
stuff so that's that's kind of
problematic
um so i
actually do disable javascript for
web browsing but again it is kind of a
pain
but you know that was that was the
number one recommendation from my
security expert
so uh okay so how do you actually do
this there's a bunch of plug-ins
the plug-in for firefox is noscript
and i believe safescript is the plugin
for chrome
and the way this is going to work is
when you go visit a particular web page
if that web page has javascript
associated with it the javascript won't
run sometimes this will end up just
giving you a blank web page
most notably i think forbes will not
allow will not even display
anything if you're writing javascript
because they're using javascript for
their advertising anyway so
what you need to do is there's going to
be a little indicator telling you that
javascript is blocked
and so you can kind of look at that
little icon and see how much javascript
associated with web page is being
blocked
and then what you can do is if you click
on it it will provide a list of the
actual javascript files that this web
page is trying to access
and you can turn some of them off and
turn some of them on and so
you'll be like well clearly i need to
allow
canvas to access javascript but
i see there's this advertising network
and you know i do know that sometimes
the advertising networks do
send some sketchy stuff uh another
suggestion
that some people have is to use no ads
but i i don't feel comfortable with that
because
i do realize that there's a lot of these
independent websites that's
the only way they're paying their bills
so i leave the ads on
but if the ads are using javascript that
gets a little bit sketchier and uh
yeah anyway so um so this is the way no
scripts or safescript works basically
uh you can whitelist a bunch of these
you could say oh
um scripts that are coming from
such a such a website that's always fine
but
otherwise i want you to ask i do
recommend it but
it is kind of a pain so one possibly
like i actually run
two web browsers like i have one web
browser that i only use to access
my bank uh and
my email and that's it and then any
other web browsing i either do
on my ipads which again you know as i
mentioned before i'm much less worried
about the ipad because it is more of a
walled garden
uh it's harder for people to break out
of that
or i access it from a web browser that
has no scripts on
okay another issue that comes up
multi-factor authentication
um the idea of multi-factor
authentication is when you're logging
into a website
in addition to knowing your name and
your password you should have
some additional factors and so what are
these different factors well
one factor is something that you know
that would typically be your password
another potential factor is something
you have such as a cell phone
or uh some sort of security token
another possible factor is something you
are like
this is you or yourself but like you
have
a fingerprint you have your retinal
pattern
so something that's unique about you
because of who you are
um and so the idea is you should have at
least two of these in order to access
a um a website or you know a remote
resource
it's the idea here is if your password
leaks
and somebody has your name and your
password unless they have this
extra factor here um they won't be able
to access your uh
your information or your banks or
banking accounting or whatever so
i strongly recommend on any website that
you can you turn on multi-factor
authentication
particularly email remember your email
is your keys to everything if somebody
gets access to your email account
ultimately that means they also has
access to your
your financial information because your
financial information is probably tied
to your email account
i can go ahead and reset the password
and bang
it'll send it new password information
to
uh to your email so your email is the
key to everything
keep that super super secure and then of
course financial
websites um and so typically email
and financial websites will allow you to
turn on two-factor authentication i
strongly strongly recommend you you do
it the most common two-factor
authentication
is sending a text message to your phone
so going back to what we said before
you know something you know your
password but in addition something you
have you have your cell phone
uh therefore it's not a hacker because
they wouldn't have your cell phone
um they might be able to get your
password somehow
but they won't have your cell phone now
there is a
bit of a problem with this because it
turns out the sms system is not secure
that's the text messaging
the standard text messaging system apple
internal imessaging is much more secure
than the standard
cell phone messaging system
sms traffic is not encrypted
and it's possible to spoof the system
and to pretend to be something that you
aren't so
that's kind of problematic in addition
hackers and scammers have
started stealing people's telephone
numbers
so basically they claim to be you
and get a new phone and get that phone
directed
and have cell phone messages to your
phone actually sent to that new phone
instead of to your cell phone so that's
all pretty problematic
um on the other hand you know if if
this isn't a determined attack or trying
to attack you specifically this is
somebody who got a list of
a whole bunch of passwords from
somewhere um this will still
probably be pretty good so you know
if your choices are do this text
messaging based two-factor
authentication or
no two-factor authentication at all do
the text-based two-factor authentication
it's way better than not having
two-factor authentication
so what's the alternative well some
websites support a
additional alternative method of
multi-factor authentication using
something called an authenticator
now this can be a physical device that
displays numbers on it
at random intervals or it could be a
cell phone app
they both basically do the same thing
and so
they are creating what are referred to
as pseudo-random numbers so they look
like they're random numbers but they
aren't actually random numbers
uh what they actually are is they are a
sequence of numbers
generated based on a seed number
and so as long as you start with the
state's same seed number
you will receive the same sequence of
pseudorandom numbers after the initial
seed
and so the idea here is if
your
cell phone app or your
physical authentication device starts
with the same seed number as
the web server that you're trying to
communicate with
you will both be able to generate the
same sequence of numbers that
look like they're random but they're
actually pseudo-random and they will
match exactly
um now it turns out that uh
the websites actually use a slightly
different technique combining both this
idea of a pseudo-random number
along with the current time um
but it's basically the same sort of idea
you start off with the seed
there's a sequence it takes the seed
that's
the sequence and the current time into
account and
based on that it can generate a number
and it will be the exact same number as
somebody else who started off with the
same seed
and knows what the current time is and
so that's the way these work and the
idea is that
only you have that seed and the web
server has that seed and if some hacker
has your account even if they've
stolen your telephone number but
hopefully not your phone
then uh you know those those numbers
will uniquely
match and there's no way somebody else
that didn't know what the random
the initial random seed was uh would be
able to reproduce it
um it's also possible to use biometrics
um this was the
something you are that we saw with the
the possible factors so something you
know
something you have or something you are
um
so this could be like fingerprints or
retinal eye pattern
security experts seem kind of like not
so hot on this idea
i have heard some people say well if
it's an additional factor
that's fine but it should not be the
only factor
and so one of the problems is that you
can't change it
so like once your retinal eye pattern is
out there it's out there
um once somebody knows what your
fingerprint looks like
they know what your fingerprint looks
like and you know it's potentially
possible to fake out these systems if
you know what fingerprint looks like
um and so uh just as an example of
how your fingerprints get out there well
the united states office of personal
management this is the
bureau that's responsible among other
things doing security checks
got hacked and over 21 million people's
fingerprints were stolen
so great and i know i have fingerprints
that are registered
with the state of california because i
teach high school students during the
summer so
everybody that teaches summer school you
need to get your fingerprints registered
um and so you know do i trust
uh i i don't know where they're being
stored i don't know whose response their
storage but like do i trust them not to
get hacked
do i trust them not to get hacked enough
to trust my bank account to them
so uh that is the problem with
biometrics
okay some things to be thinking about as
far as your passwords go
there's a number of possible concerns
with passwords the first one is
passwords can be brute force so this
means trying all the possible
combinations
and it's been interesting watching as
people go like oh
eight character long passwords are fine
no now you need nine character long
passwords and basically what's
been going on here is the faster and
faster computers get
the less amount of time it's going to
take for somebody to uh
try all the different combinations
anyway longer passwords are better than
shorter passwords
because each additional character
requires
you know a huge number of additional uh
possibilities and so they need to try a
lot more if they're doing a brute force
attack
in addition if you use both uppercase
letters and lowercase letters again that
increases the number of possible
combinations
if you include digits and punctuations
not all websites allow you use
punctuations which is kind of annoying
but if you use digits and punctuation
that will even
more greatly increase the number of
combinations so
you want to maximize the difficulty of
somebody guessing your password by just
brute forcing trying all the different
possible combinations
uh use uppercase letters lowercase
letters digits and punctuations
um also you know i said the main thing
is
the length of password but uh attackers
also have a list of
the most common password used so like
don't come up with something really
cutesy that like maybe
other people also use because that's
probably on the list of the most common
passwords
and these are things that the attacker
will try first
use different passwords for different
websites why
well the first thing is like if you've
got a bunch of random hobby websites
uh do you know who owns that website do
you trust two onsen website
do you trust them one to not be a hacker
but also
two do you trust their computer security
are they going to keep their computer
security updated so just just to provide
you an example
um one of my passwords is out there in
the wild there are lists
that you can use to check and see if
your passwords are out there
and it turns out it got uh stolen from a
website called titanquest.net titan
quest was
a video game similar to some of you may
have
seen diablo or play diablo it's kind of
like diablo except for
a little bit more classic greek
uh greek themed um
and yeah so i created an account on that
website and
they got hacked and that password is out
there in the wild
um and even professional websites do get
hacked for example the playstation
network a while back got hacked
there have been a variety of other
people that have gotten hacked
so um ideally if they know what they're
doing
if they get hacked hopefully your
password should still be
protected because it's referred to
what's called
um hashed but uh
but you know they don't always do don't
always follow good
safe competing practices so if they get
probably increases the chance they're
gonna get hacked if they're already
uh not providing safe competing
practices and then they get hacked and
that password is now out there
and in fact stanford says you should not
use the stanford password on any other
website but you definitely want
different passwords like do not use your
financial passwords on
a random website a really bad idea and
again reminder
your email account is the key to the
kingdom so you know
don't use that password or anything else
either
some experts suggest using a passphrase
instead of a password
and so a passphrase is essentially a
bunch of words strung together
um so uh the idea here
is that past phrases are easy to
remember
so like if you're like uh i don't know
cardinal computer
flomo hopefully you can remember that
because floma is the best dorm on campus
and obviously cardinal's really great
and i already forgot what my middle word
was but it's easier than a random
sequence of 12
uppercase lowercase digits punctuation
and the idea here is
that what you can do with the passphrase
is you can make the passphrase a lot
longer
uh so you know if you've got 12 random
characters
versus you have a sequence of four words
typed together which
end up being 25 characters well 25
characters is a lot of random
combinations to come up with
and since there are over 50 000 words in
the english language even if they know
that there are four words
there's a heck of a lot of combinations
in order to do that
unfortunately research has shown that
past phrases aren't as random as they
should be
this is from bonaire and chatova i i
mentioned bonane shatova because
joe bonet uh was a former student who i
wrote a letter of wreck the god of grad
school and i ran into
uh i was reading up my passphrase and i
ran into his research i was like go
joe anyway so
basically what they found was that uh
people are not coming up with random
passphrases they're coming up with
phrases that fall specific rules they're
grammatical rules they're you know
and so the idea here is that
if the past phrases are not actually
completely
a sequence of four completely random
uh words then you are not getting full
advantage
of the idea that past phrases are longer
but they're safer
and in fact it greatly reduces the
security on passphrases
i think they're still generally
considered even if you have four not
completely random words
um i mean if you come with a common
phrase you're screwed but
uh in general if there are four semi
random words um
you still should have pretty good
security but just be aware you
really want to pick stuff that's
completely random you don't want to be
like
oh this is a cool set of words that
completely make sense together
that other people might also come up
with that's that's a really bad idea
okay now the possibility is a password
manager
so password manager is going to keep
track of all your passwords
uh it will come up with new passwords
for you which are completely randomized
and are of
nice good length um and the basic idea
here is you have a master password that
gets
into the password manager and then once
you've
done that you don't need to remember any
of your other passwords
um password managers are also
really nice because they protect you
from phishing attacks you
recall you know phishing attacks is when
you get something like an email
claim to be for your bank you click on
it it takes your website that looks
exactly like your bank
what the password manager is going to do
is it could be like
uh your bank is bank of america
this is bank or america it looks really
close but it's a different name
i'm not going to enter in your password
information here now what you need to do
is if well first of all don't ever click
on the links
that's still true whether or not you're
running a password manager or not but
like
um you know if you go to a website
that you think you have a password for
in your password manager and it doesn't
get filled out automatically
you should double check and be like huh
i wonder why my password manager doesn't
like this
like is it that i misspelled it and this
is a hacker's website
or like what's going on here so i do
think that
this is a big advantage of using the
password managers that
they should help prevent phishing where
somebody's trying to act like it's a
website
that you know in order to get your
login information because the password
manager is going to be like
that's not the right website i have the
password for the real website
and that is not the real website and i'm
not going to autofill in the information
where if you're glancing at that website
you might be like well it looks like my
real website i guess i'm going to go
ahead and type my information in
password manager won't do that
the one potential downside is the
password managers there are
a there have been a number of security
incidents with
password managers including one of them
which got completely hacked so
i don't know if there's any great
solutions but um
but the security experts do seem to
think that the password managers are a
good idea in general so
uh you know i tend to listen to the
experts on this
all right um so there's one last
lecture on security which is going to be
super short which is just going to be
a quick summary of uh
suggestions for personal security
including some of the ones that we just
covered here on passwords
i'll talk to you all soon